[Musica]
anch'io sono stato un bambino con
te ricordi belli e dei porti anche meno
belli
all'età di sette anni dopo il divorzio
dei miei genitori una delle mie prime
scelte della vita è stata quella di
decidere se vivere con il mio papà ho
con la mia mamma
piangendo in un'aula di tribunale
decisi di vivere con il mio papà perché
nel frattempo il giudice aveva già
segnato le mie sorelle la mamma
per molto tempo considerato quel momento
come un'ingiustizia subita dalla vita
ogni sera prima di andare a letto
immaginavo come sarebbe stato un mondo
più giusto e più bello per tutti
per scelta fin da piccolo ho sempre
cercato una soluzione a tutto
di fronte ad una difficoltà ho imparato
a chiedermi se non io chi se non ora
quando
come posso fare
guardavo a quello che avevo e non a
quello che mi mancava e con quello che
avevo mi impegnavo per realizzare il
massimo risultato
poi crescendo di fronte all'opportunità
che la vita mi dava ho sempre optato per
la strada che mi permetteva di scegliere
chi volevo essere scegliere chi volevo
essere e questo mi ha portato a fare
un'importante carriera come manager di
multinazionali nel settore tessile
lavorare con i più importanti stilisti
nel mondo aprire più di 35 società in
italia e all'estero ea ricevere diverse
autorevoli riconoscimenti
ma il percorso non è stato semplice
il primo passo è stato capire chi
davvero volevo essere una consapevolezza
che è nata nel momento in cui il mio
corpo ha incominciato a mandarmi dei
segnali di salute poco rassicuranti e
non capivo il motivo apparentemente
stavo bene stavo facendo un importante
carriera professionale in più guadagnavo
tanti soldi
eppure
era come se il mio procedere nella vita
ostacolato da un disallineamento
non a parte quello che con la mia mente
mi imponeva di fare e dall'altra parte
quello che il mio cuore mi incitava
realizzare
era come se camminiamo in modo
disequilibrato immaginate la testa che
va da una parte le braccia che vanno
dall altra e le gambe che vanno dall
altra parte ancora
vi assicuro veramente difficile e stato
un momento impegnativo che però mi ha
portato a conoscermi ancora più in
profondità e conoscendomi a creare un
maggiore allineamento tra quei cinque
fattori che ritengo fondamentali nelle
nostre vite mission e
vision e identità valori obiettivi la
missione il nostro perché siamo in
questa vita non so scopo supremo se non
siamo allineati con la nostra missione
la nostra vita perde un po di
significato
ad esempio la mia a che fare con le
persone a rendere tutti più consapevoli
rispetto al proprio talento così che nel
valorizzarlo possano realizzare il
proprio scopo nella vita
la visione una lavagna bianca da
riempire e visualizzando nella nostra
mente tutto ciò che vogliamo realizzare
che cosa vogliamo realizzare nel mio
caso un ambiente potenziante ispiranti
per tutti i talenti nel mondo
l'identità quella vera quella che prende
luce solo nel momento in cui ci
prendiamo il coraggio di spogliarci
delle maschere delle corazze che ci
costruiamo nel corso della nostra vita
siamo dei genitori degli studenti degli
imprenditori e se andiamo un po più a
fondo quali sono le nostre passioni che
vorremmo essere
e poi i nostri valori i principi etici
che ci guidano nelle scelte quello che
riteniamo bene o male
giusto o sbagliato
onestà correttezza trasparenza sono solo
un esempio
è solo nel momento in cui abbiamo
definito questi punti che possiamo
andare a individuare quelli che sono i
nostri veri obiettivi
e nel momento in cui i nostri obiettivi
sono chiari
allora ecco che la nostra visione ha la
possibilità di realizzarsi
ogni mattina per scegliere chi voglio
essere prendo un po di tempo per un
esercizio che vi invito a fare vostro
nella prima parte mi ripeto i punti
dell'allineamento la mia missione la mia
visione la mia identità
i miei valori in sé obiettivi
nella seconda parte ripenso a quello che
ho fatto il giorno precedente
per comprendere quello che è più
allineato con la mia centratura oppure
quello che le meno e alla fine capire
come posso migliorare nella terza parte
il focalizza sul giorno entrante e
immagino come posso realizzarlo al
meglio allora prendo la mia agenda
scrivo i cinque obiettivi che voglio
raggiungere nell'arco della giornata e
so che la mia giornata finirà solo
quando li avrò portato a termine con
successo
allora ecco che quando siamo persone più
allineate quando stiamo bene con noi
stessi incominciamo a vibrare di una
sana energia che risuona nella stessa
frequenza d'onda di altre persone che
come noi condividono gli stessi valori e
gli stessi ideali persone con le quali
costruiamo nuove relazioni nuove
collaborazioni nuovi progetti
credo che i progetti più importanti che
realizziamo insieme sono quelli che
donano parte dei nostri benefici al bene
per le altre persone e questo non so
bene perché da più di dieci anni sono
impegnate a sviluppare la più grande
organizzazione al mondo nell'ambito del
marketing relazionale
ricopre ruoli strategici sia a livello
nazionale che internazionale
insieme ad altri miei colleghi
costruiamo dei team e di imprenditori
professionisti che hanno delle attività
complementari tra di loro che decidono
di collaborare insieme al fine di
sviluppare reciproci business è la cosa
più bella e quando questi imprenditori
decidono di donare parte dei loro
successi alla comunità due mesi fa
un gruppo di lecco ha deciso di
bonificare un parco che era stato
trascurato in accordo con il comune e
alcuni giovani studenti hanno ripulito
il terreno inserito nuove piante nuovi
fiori e hanno costruito delle nuove
panchine
in giorno dell'inaugurazione è stato
estremamente emozionante
pensare che qualcuno ha dato qualcosa
senza che nessuno avesse chiesto e senza
nulla chiedere in cambio
e la risposta del bene che ognuno di noi
può dare
al mondo in cui noi viviamo
ed è quando ci dedichiamo un bene
superiore che va al di là delle nostre
vite che attiviamo un processo
generativo che coinvolge tutte quelle
persone che decidono di andare oltre il
lato materiale delle cose
persone
che decidono di guardare il bene comune
persone che decidono di guardare il
valore di quello che c'è nella vita e
per me è come sentirmi in un flusso in
grado di contaminare con la sua azione
rigenerante la mia coscienza e la
coscienza delle persone con cui vivo e
come un vento caldo benefico che ci
attraversa e va oltre ogni confine
geografico e politico
è un momento in cui ognuno diventa il
catalizzatore del successo dell'altro e
tutti insieme del nostro successo come
comunità questo è il motivo per cui
attraverso il progetto bollino etico
sociale sono impegnato a rendere le
aziende più consapevoli rispetto a nuovi
modelli di business dirette
all'innovazione sociale e alla
sostenibilità ambientale
è una svolta epocale come anche
documentato dagli studi dell'università
ca foscari di venezia sono sempre di più
le aziende che producono azioni ad alto
impatto sul benessere dei lavoratori e
delle loro famiglie
nel creare nuovi progetti nuovi prodotti
nuovi modelli anti pongono al profitto
il desiderio di migliorare la vita delle
persone
e lo fanno dando priorità alle relazioni
con il territorio e alla comunità alla
quale appartengono è un cambio di
paradigma
per me come un sogno che si sta
trasformando in realtà
penso che quel bambino che immaginava un
giorno un mondo più bello e più giusto
per tutti oggi sarebbe orgoglioso di me
e adesso vi invito a fare un esercizio
prendete un foglio di carta e scriveteci
sono felice
sì o no
se avete risposto di sì sono veramente
contento per voi per le persone con le
quali vivete e per l'energia che donate
al mondo
se invece avete risposto di no vi invito
qui e ora a iniziare il vostro percorso
di consapevolezza
sullo stesso foglio andate a inserire la
data di oggi e poi elencati i seguenti
punti
la mia missione
che cosa volete lasciare dopo il vostro
passaggio in questa vita
la mia visione con quale progetto volete
realizzare il vostro scopo
la mia identità chi volete essere
veramente
i miei valori
andatevi a identificarne 5 e metteteli
in ordine di priorità
i miei obiettivi
partite con uno
fate in modo che sia specifico
misurabile e datevi un tempo per
raggiungerlo e poi prendetevi una
settimana da oggi per andare a riempire
di contenuti ognuno di questi punti non
importa se li finirete ci vorrà un po di
tempo e anche un po di studi per
arrivare a fare in modo che vi
identifichino completamente la parte più
bella sarà il percorso che vi porterà ad
essere delle persone sempre più
allineate fiere del vostro talento e
soprattutto centrate sulla vostra
vocazione
se non tutti
se non ora quando
cosa puoi fare
scegli chi vuoi essere
e realizza lo scopo per il quale sei
nato
il premio
sarà la felicità
quella vera quella che parte dal cuore
ed ha senso ad ogni cosa che facciamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]